it seems like it's been nothing but  fireworks for Katy Perry and Orlando  Bloom since they started dating but the  popstar is revealing the one thing about  her boyfriend that drives her crazy  literally Katie said driving far to see  him drives her crazy everyone's really  crazy 31 year old popstar recently  opened up to Women's Wear Daily and said  quote my boyfriend lives in Malibu and  getting used to that drive was like are  you kidding me what kind of life is this  Perry added that his house is far  there's no pop over the singer admits  she never really got used to Malibu  because it's halfway to Santa Barbara  where Katy grew up she explained quote I  grew up in the poorest part actually my  boyfriend didn't even believe me and I  was like I'm gonna drive you by my house  and you can Google Earth it it's all  good the pair of first sparks romance  rumors in January when they were spotted  together at the Golden Globes